we're joined from south london by
labour's shadow community secretary
steve reads mr reed lovely to have you
on the program this morning um
you will be as aware as any of us about
the state of these brexit negotiations
um
labour party must be loving the prospect
uh that there'll be a no deal at the end
of all of this
once again you wouldn't have to tell us
exactly what kind of deal you'd want to
sign up to
well the the last thing we need is is no
deal in these circumstances
it's one year and one day exactly since
boris johnson won an 80-seat majority in
the house of commons
promising to get brexit done with an
oven-ready
brexit deal that he had ready to agree
with the european union now we're right
at the 11th hour now
aren't we the uh the deal is not yet
done it needs to be got over the line
because
um we cannot tolerate uh in this country
the the damage that a no deal brexit
would do and nor can we tolerate the
uncertainty
that a no deal brexit would do one of
the reasons people voted
for to get brexit done was they've had
enough for four and a half years of
going round and round in circles over
brexit
they want this ended they want they want
confidence and security that we can move
our country
forwards a no deal brexit would simply
mean the
negotiations restarted again next month
only britain would be in a far weaker
position so boris johnson needs to now
do
what he told the the country a year ago
he was ready to do
and get brexit done sure but you're not
telling me that the labour party led by
sir kirsten a lawyer of course
would ever sign up to a deal in which
the european union could unilaterally
introduce tariffs
uh on our products by their
determination that we have
uh deviated from the standards that they
set you can't tell me that
sir would sign up to that one
well the the the we're facing now is
that boris johnson
claiming to have 98 of this deal done
now just two percent of it left to go it
must be
possible to find a way to to bridge that
remaining
two percent but one of the sticking
points seems to be
boris johnson wanting the powers to do
something he claims he doesn't want to
do anyway which makes the whole thing
more surreal you know he's arguing for
the powers to water down
employment rights and environmental
standards now
labor doesn't want to see that happen
the country doesn't want to see that
that happen so there is a deal to be
done here as one of your
your earlier interviewees was saying
economies are interdependent
uh these days we have to take shared
decisions if we're going to trade
with each other and taking a shared
decision is not a breach of
sovereignty it's exercising sovereignty
we have to get this deal
over the line we have to complete the
remaining two percent if that's all that
remains to be done
and we need to get this deal done so the
british economy and the british people
after four years of uncertainty can move
forwards
sure but there is clearly though a
difference between the interdependence
as described by the by the spanish
foreign minister
and the idea that's being pushed by this
government which you know if we accept
the deal that is on the table
we would be supplicants to the european
union
i don't think that's true this is about
taking shared decisions now
boris johnson is arguing at this very
late stage
that he wants the powers to water down
employment rights
and reduce environmental standards and
environmental protections
these are things he claims he doesn't
want to do anyway so it shouldn't really
be
a sticking point there's a deal to be
done if the if what the european union
wants to achieve
and what the british government wants to
achieve are the same uh which is what
they are both saying then this is
this is a surreal position we've got
ourselves in where he is preparing boris
johnson is preparing
if he if he breaks his promise to get
brexit done uh and deliver a
uh deliver a brexit deal he's preparing
to sacrifice the british economy
over something he doesn't even want to
do it's just crazy
sure but again there is a difference
isn't there between you know
a relationship with the european union
that grows and evolves and a
relationship in which we are dictated to
from brussels in terms of
of standards can you honestly tell the
17 and a half million people who voted
for brexit
that it is that we will be leaving the
european union
if in perpetuity we have to stick
to their definition of what standards
are rather than being able to
decide upon it ourselves
it would be a shared decision and i
don't think for a minute
people that voted for brexit in doing so
thought they were going to lower their
own employment rights or lose their
their own chance of a decent and
well-paid job
people voted for brexit because they
thought it was going to be better for
the country
and better for the economy now we need
this deal
over the line now this this this final
sticking point
over something that the prime minister
says he doesn't even want to do anyway
seems to me absolutely surreal there's a
deal to be done
it needs to be done today we could just
be hours away from it let's just end the
uncertainty of the last four and a half
years
and move forwards with a relationship
with our biggest trading partner in the
world the european union that will
benefit all of us
sure but what then would labour do
differently what concessions would
labour make in all of this to get a deal
done let's okay take fishing
how many years would you allow european
union trollers in our waters
well it was boris johnson that said he
had an oven ready deal it wasn't the
labour party that said we had an oven
ready
on that he's had 12 months to get this
over the line and it's still not over
the line
he promised the british people he was so
confident in his deal
he said he didn't even need to do any
planning for no deal circumstances
because it wasn't going to happen
because he had a deal ready to go he
said he had a deal not labor
let's see that deal let's get it over
the line and let's all move on together
mr reed whilst we have you we really
should dwell on uncovered 19 and of
course christmas is very much in
all of our minds at the moment i i just
wonder whether or not
you feel that it would be wrong to relax
uh
restrictions for that five day christmas
uh period
given the numbers that we are seeing
from various parts of the country
including london
in terms of infection
well you know people have had a very
difficult year
nine months where people haven't been
able to go to work properly see their
families properly
people are looking forward to christmas
it's not going to be a normal christmas
of course
and the the rise that we're seeing well
the reported rise in infection rates
in many areas under tier 2 actually is
half of them it's not just london it's
very very
worrying now we'll get an assessment
based on the data on the 16th
of this month and we'll need to see
where we are then but the key thing is
we need to follow the science
and we need to do everything we can to
keep people safe so
the situation will be under review until
we understand from the science
what is driving the increase in
infection rates and what can be done to
manage that i mean the key thing is all
of us need to do whatever we can to
follow the rules and the guidelines
to stop the infection rate growing but
until we understand what's causing that
it's very difficult to say what we
should do as a result of that but
we should be only days away from finding
that out we should indeed uh steve reed
lovely to see you this morning merry
christmas when it comes
merry christmas thank you